I'm back in Chinatown in London
and about to come face-to-face with some
key members of the Chinese restaurant
community some invited quite low the
restaurants locally it's gonna meet me
show them what I've just gone through
and maybe bring them up to speed and
what's actually happening because I
don't think they quite realize
thanks so much for coming good to see
you how are you the plan is to show five
of London's leading Chinese restaurants
some footage of my journey and to
persuade them to take shark fin soup off
their menus I asked you here today for
an open debate and I'm not here to
accuse anyone of any wrongdoing or
misgiving but after the investigating
the sort of shark finning industry in my
program I'm convinced by decreasing the
demand for shark fin soup it's possible
to lessen the demand for fins to give
them an idea of the scale of the problem
I'm showing them what I found in
Kaohsiung port in Taiwan we're gonna
call the roof please
my god and he's out of laid out to join
perfect thousands of the matter
this is incredible is every roof like
this and Chinese cooking is always and
has been renowned for using everything
five percent you know of the fin 95
percent as a by-product
you're wasting more than you're using I
guess yeah it's something that's been
through tradition that shark's fin you
know is prized there are no sharp
recipes aligner using the meat and so
when I look at that I feel that yes we
should use the rest of the shark as well
as the thing otherwise not at all I need
to open their eyes to the barbaric and
wasteful reality of Finan
why was it shocking everybody in this
room is here for reason because you can
make a difference and that difference
would be to start alongside me with a
campaign to ban shark fin soup on the
menu here in Chinatown
the Chinese they've always looked at
shark fin as a food product and I think
they need to change they need to reflect
and do make a band's judgment to feel
wow I didn't know this shot comes from
this
would you stop serving sharpen soup yes
I think so after watching this program I
would go back through my thoughts and
tell them you know how I feel about this
to be honest you know it is shopping
their shop
would you stop 7:00 sharp in soup I
think we all don't ever do this and that
look at service you would I thought you
think of all the restaurants in this
room agree then there is that starting
point personally as a consumer I won't
be consuming it the meter went really
well
it was a small but very powerful group
of restaurants and if they're now
agreeing with me to stop serving
champion soup that is a huge huge
advantage because now others may follow
the journey has been incredible and for
me has been the most dangerous but the
most fascinating trip I've ever done
Jesus Christ as shark after shark alpha
shark
sharks they've been here for over 400
million years and there are some shark
populations out there that have gone
down by 9 percent in 10 years and he's
upset I'm here but who's regulating this
if we don't start to make a difference
now they may not be around by the end of
this century no bowl of soup is worth
that
leave them alone and respect their
beauty